For our Chapter Readings and Current Events,
we actually respond online before we come
to the classroom, and that's really interesting
because as the leaders of the discussion,
you get to read everyone's opinions on everything.
And that's really unique... in that the students
may not do that.
And you can see as a class where everyone
stands.
And it's really interesting just to learn
everyone's different backgrounds, the diversity
of the class, and the opinions they have on
education.
I think that it's good because you can kind
of see where the conversation will go; it's
not just...
I mean we have the format where we have three
questions asked, and then we have each person
respond.
But, it's even better to see how people respond
to each other in their posts, where you can
have one person just say like, "According
to what Christina said, she brought up a really
interesting point, but here's my reaction.'
You can't really get that if you just stick
to the same three questions, or the same format.
It kind of takes also the student's part to
bounce off of each other."